The ‘devil on your shoulder’, your ‘guardian
angel’; these are expressions that we’ve
all heard countless times.
Of course, they’re not supposed to be taken
literally.
None of us have a heavenly spirit looking
over us and protecting us from harm, in the
same way that nobody really has a little red-skinned
imp whispering encouragement to commit atrocious
deeds in someone’s ear.
They’re metaphors: guardian angel refers
to any instance of seemingly divine intervention,
but is more often a coincidence that ends
up benefitting a person when they need it
most.
And the devil on your shoulder, that’s temptation,
the little voice in the back of your head
that sometimes eggs you on to do something
you know you shouldn’t.
But what if there was a being that was both,
a demonic, malicious creature that also acted
as a guardian for someone unable to protect
themselves?
Is it even possible for a being to be both
angel and devil?
And who out there could ever qualify for such
holy and hellish protection?
Ombre Rouge was once a fairly normal place
to live.
A small Louisiana town in one of the smallest
of these fifty United States.
Its name was derived from the French language,
translating to ‘Red Shadow’, an ominous
name for a township that was otherwise so
uninteresting and forgettable.
In fact, if things had never panned out the
way they had, Ombre Rouge would have stayed
that way, just a place where nothing interesting
ever happened.
All of that changed, of course, when the disappearances
started.
For anyone who might be too young to remember
them, the mid-2000s were a turbulent time.
The Iraq War was in full swing, and a nationwide
financial crisis was rapidly approaching.
But, in the midst of all this global chaos
and instability, the residents of Ombre Rouge
were soon to be caught in the thralls of their
very own shared torment.
At first, like with most bad things, it started
small.
One person went missing, an unfortunate occurrence,
but not exactly unheard of.
Sadly, these things happen, especially when
you live so close to the swamplands of Louisiana.
People wander out into the marsh, under the
searing heat of the sun, only to suffer heatstroke,
collapse, and end up buried in the dark, dank
mud, never to be seen again.
Few of those living in the town took much
notice of the first disappearance.
Apart from the missing person’s relatives,
many just shrugged off the news; as sad as
it was, most of the townsfolk were just grateful
it hadn’t happened to any of their own family
or friends.
Maybe it was that ignorance, that lack of
vigilance or reaction, that meant a second
resident would also be reported missing, not
long after the first.
But this time was different: unlike the previous
disappearance, this one had an eyewitness.
Clement Donovan – known to locals as ‘Clem’
– had spotted a passer-by while taking out
bags of garbage.
This unassuming pedestrian was the second
disappearance victim.
Thinking little of the man, who just seemed
to be walking home, Clem went back inside.
A split second later, he heard a scream from
outside and rushed back to his dimly-lit porch.
It was there that Clem claimed he saw… something
retreating towards the nearby woods.
However, Clem’s wild story of something
not quite human wasn’t taken seriously by
local police.
He’d even managed to snap a grainy photo
on his clamshell cell phone, but back in 2005,
phone cameras were nowhere near as advanced
as they are today.
Most Ombre Rouge locals wrote Clem off as
a crazy old man at best.
But at worse, it made him look like someone
who was trying to exploit or make light of
the disappearances, something that garnered
him a lot of dirty looks from his neighbors.
That was, until a number of other residents
started reporting they had also witnessed
a humanoid creature.
It’s hard to say if any of these eyewitnesses
were genuine, and how many were just people
latching on to Clem’s story.
Regardless, the disappearances hadn’t stopped
and it didn’t take long for an unknown organization
to roll into Ombre Rouge after hearing the
rumors of a creature sighting.
A few residents, even the local sheriff’s
department, thought these shady figures were
a division of forensic specialists here to
aid in the investigations into the missing
persons.
The more conspiratorial folks living in the
town had a different explanation, that the
newcomers were a deep state-controlled, top-secret
government group, there to assess the possibility
that there really was some kind of monster
on the loose.
Not long after this group had arrived in Ombre
Rouge, the number of residents going missing
seemed to dwindle.
On the eighteenth of December 2005, they packed
up and left town, giving no explanation to
the local police.
Nobody knew if this secretive ‘Foundation’
had actually uncovered the perpetrator responsible
for all the disappearances, if there even
was any creature like the rumors said.
But whatever had transpired in that Louisiana
swamp town, one thing was clear: the moment
the Foundation left, nobody else went missing
from Ombre Rouge.
Or at least, not for over a decade.
Before then, however, little else of note
happened in Ombre Rouge after the initial
spate of missing person cases.
That is, apart from a car accident that took
place just under a year after the various
disappearances ended.
A heavily-injured man by the name of Simon
Hays was taken to a local hospital, suffering
from a severe concussion.
Simon had been involved in a collision with
a car on the eleventh of November 2006.
The doctors that examined him determined that
Simon had been left with short-term retrograde
amnesia, a condition that affected all his
memories from prior to the accident.
It was due to this that he was unable to recall
events that occurred in the years before he’d
sustained his injuries.
Now, what is it that makes a random, if unfortunate
car accident victim so significant?
Well, Simon Hays actually became the first
person in Ombre Rouge to be declared missing
in almost a decade.
In 2016, ten years after his accident and
eleven after the original slew of disappearances,
Simon vanished when returning to his hometown
in Louisiana to visit his family.
Naturally, Simon Hays wouldn’t be the last
familiar face to return to the town.
A repetition of such similar and strange occurrences
as before also brought the mysterious Foundation
rolling back in.
Little did the townsfolk know, in the year
that had followed the group’s original exodus
from Ombre Rouge, they had lost something.
On the exact same day Simon suffered his accident,
whatever it was the Foundation had left town
with had managed to escape.
Perhaps this was a purely coincidental occurrence,
but what if it wasn’t?
After all, road traffic collisions take place
all the time, all over the world.
But an accident happening in a town with a
history of people going missing, on the exact
same day that this… thing escaped captivity?
Maybe there was a link between these two events.
At the very least, the Foundation seemed to
think so.
Some of the more astute people living in the
swamp-side town noticed black, armored transport
vehicles moving into their neighborhoods,
men in body armor locking down the whole of
Ombre Rouge.
These didn’t seem like local police, they
weren’t even the National Guard, although
they were certainly heavily armed enough to
cause concern.
This unit of specially trained operatives
quickly took control of the entire township,
their authority never questioned by the sheriff’s
department.
The place was small enough, isolated by surrounding
swamps and marshland, that it was easy for
Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6 to get away with
an operation like this.
Before the people of Ombre Rouge had time
to argue, the Task Force had already begun
their investigation.
The newest series of disappearances had started
in 2016 with Simon Hays mysteriously vanishing,
and had continued two years later in 2018.
Just like the first spate back in 2005, there
were sporadic and unconfirmed eyewitness accounts
of a creature, shaped like a human but considerably
taller, almost two meters in height.
Most witnesses reported only ever seeing this
local bogeyman at night time, making it much
harder to see in detail, although a few seemed
to state its skin was deep red, unlike any
natural human skin tone.
While before, residents of the Louisiana swamp
town had brushed off stories like this as
nothing more than rumors and urban legends,
the Foundation seemed pretty receptive to
the idea of some kind of monster on the loose
in the marshland.
And after all, they had good reason to believe
such an outlandish story… because it was
the same creature that had already escaped
from them in 2006.
Continuing their investigation into the link
between Simon Hays and this creature, Mobile
Task Force Epsilon-6 – also known by the
codename the ‘Village Idiots’ – arrived
at Hays’ place of residence.
Kicking the door down, breaching the house,
they began a room-by-room sweep, looking for
any clues that would explain why the monster
they’d captured escaped on the same day
as Simon’s accident.
One of the MTF operatives uncovered something,
an envelope stashed in the home Simon had
grown up in.
He opened it cautiously, a collection of papers
that were contained inside came spilling out.
They were a series of simple drawings on paper
that seemed to be more than a few years old.
The crudeness of the hand-scrawled pictures
and age of the paper seemed to imply they
had been created by a child.
A number of the drawings depicted the same
thing: a red-skinned creature, just like the
one the townsfolk had reported seeing.
With them was a note, written by Simon’s
mother, which read:
“Found these old drawings of yours.
Thought you might like to see them again.
Welcome home.”
There was a link, an unclear, maybe tangential
connection but one that was growing the more
information the Foundation uncovered.
Whatever this being was, a very young Simon
Hays had seen it while growing up in Ombre
Rouge.
Due to the short-term retrograde amnesia that
he’d sustained after his accident, he wouldn’t
have remembered it, but perhaps this… thing
remembered him.
Did that mean the pair of them might be linked
somehow?
Not just by coincidence, but some kind of
connection that allowed the creature to escape
its captivity on the exact day Simon had his
car accident.
A connection that had drawn Hays back home
to Ombre Rouge, or drawn the beast to Simon
to kidnap him.
Moving fast, MTF Epsilon-6 began to rapidly
sweep the remainder of the town, searching
for any further signs that would lead them
to the whereabouts of either Simon Hays or
this elusive, crimson-skinned bogeyman.
They interviewed residents and chased cold
leads, before eventually backing their target
into a corner.
The Foundation’s MTF operatives mapped the
location of every eyewitness report of the
creature, using that information to track
it back to a possible point of origin.
It was a barn, left abandoned, practically
falling apart as it stood in a state of disrepair
just outside the small Louisiana town.
Under the cover of darkness, the task force
approached the wooden structure, weapons locked
and loaded, keeping them trained on the barn.
Cautiously moving closer, remaining on high
alert, the squad activated their night vision.
There was the low, almost undetectable sound
of movement coming from within the barn.
Slowly, the MTF’s leader pushed open the
wooden door and peeked inside.
It was there he saw what they had been looking
for, the thing that had escaped the Foundation
over ten years before: SCP-3631, a Man and
his Monster.
The beast was just over six feet tall, its
skin a bloody shade of crimson just as some
of the eyewitnesses had described.
It sported a pair of arms and bipedal legs,
giving it a humanoid shape.
However, that was exactly where its likeness
to human beings ended.
The creature, later designated as SCP-3631-1,
lacked eyes, ears, or a nose, only a wide,
gaping maw of sharp teeth.
Its face was covered in holes that twitched
and puckered like smaller, miniature mouths.
In actuality, it used these orifices for various
senses; it smelled, saw, and detected sounds
through the holes in its otherwise mostly
featureless face.
As the members of MTF Epsilon-6 entered the
barn stealthily, making sure not to alert
SCP-3631-1, they sighted something else.
Someone else was in the barn with it, a man,
not a dead victim or another monster like
SCP-3631-1, but an actual, living, breathing
human man.
MTF Epsilon-6’s commander gave his squad
the signal to engage.
Hearing the sounds of weapons cocking around
it, the creature turned and snarled, crawling
on all fours like an animalistic predator.
At first, it reared back, It wasn’t until
one member of the task force approached that
SCP-3631-1 retaliated, attacking the Foundation
operatives in a frenzy.
Following a prolonged and bloody exchange,
MTF Epsilon-6 managed to subdue the creature
and were able to once again return it to Foundation
captivity.
But this time, unlike back in 2005, they had
SCP-3631-2 as well.
As the red monster was prepped for transport,
a survivor of the task force noticed something:
an ID, perhaps a driver’s license, on the
man’s person.
The Epsilon-6 operative picked the card up,
wiping away smears of blood with a gloved
finger, enough to reveal a single, familiar
name printed on it…
Simon Hays.
Before long, just like last time, the Foundation
rolled back out of Ombre Rouge, leaving the
Louisiana townsfolk none the wiser about what
had happened there.
Little did they know the ‘Red Shadow’
hanging over their home had been lifted.
But it had come at the cost of a number of
disappearances that would remain unsolved,
people who would never be found, families
forced to go on without ever getting answers.
When he was returned to the Foundation’s
labs, SCP-3631-2 was sent for extensive examination.
Given the severity of the invasive organ transplants
he’d undergone, it was impossible to tell
if he was, in fact, Simon.
The creature had been regularly replacing
the man’s internal organs, on a monthly
basis whenever they showed signs of decay
or failing.
Somehow, despite the high risk of blood loss
and infection posed by this crude form of
surgery, the subject had remained alive.
But he was unable to speak, conscious but
showing very limited responses to stimuli.
Nobody knows why the carnivorous, nocturnal
monster SCP-3631-1 took this man captive.
In the same vein, it is unclear why the creature
felt such a need to protect him, going to
such lengths as hunting for replacement organs
from unwilling donors.
Perhaps, in a grisly, twisted way, SCP-3631-1
was the man’s guardian angel.
Or maybe more a devil on his shoulder.
I wonder, is it really possible for something
to be both?
Now go and check out “SCP-096 THE SHY GUY”
and “SCP-049 THE PLAGUE DOCTOR” for more
tales of creepy and cruel creatures that you
really don’t want to have any close encounters
with!